♪ ♪ ♪
- Sur l'échelle des malheurs,
ça ne se compare en rien
à la guerre et à ses morts.
Mais la fermeture aujourd'hui
du géant suédois dans toute
la Russie est un autre coup
b b barre et il est majeur.
Ça fait à peine une demi-heure
que les employés l'ont appris
dans cette petite succursale
de Saint-Pétersbourg. On leura ,
et après, personne ne le sait.
Au total, c'est 15 000 postes
au pays qui disparaissent.
Irina, une cliente, prend
la nouvelle avec un sourire,
mais elle ravale ses émotions.
La fermeture d'IKEA est
un autbobobobole du malheur
économique qui s'abat sur
les Russes, qui voient un monde
auquel ils s'étaient habitués
leur glisser entre les doigts.
Chez Highspot, un des nombreux
distributeurs de produits Apple
en Russie, il ne reste plus que
les démonstrateurs.
Le gérant dit qu'il a tout
vendu ce qu'il avait en stock
en deux jours et pour le double
du prix.
(en anglais)
Il sourit parce qu'il vient
tout juste de recevoir
une dernière commande placée
avant que Apple, une des marques
les plus vendues en Russie,
décide de rompre les liens
avec le pays. Il devra
s'approvisionner ailleurs,
peut-être aun.n.n.n.n.n.
Et quoi qu'en disent
les autorités, les pays
est en train de sombrer dans
une grande, grande crise
économique.
Cette femme sait très bien
que les jours de sa boutique
de souveàààààà éprouvée
par la pandémie, sont comptés.
Mais elle refuse de sombrer
dans la déprime.
Sauf qu'à chaque jour qui
passe, c'est une porte de plus
qui se ferssssssssssssssie.
Quelques heures après l'annonce
officielle en après-midi,
le plus grand magasin IKEA
de Moscou était pris d'assaut.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais à Saint-Pétersbourg,
il y avait un eeeeeee
troublant. Dans cette ville
de Russie, la plus libérale
et la plus ouverte sur l'Europe,
on entend aussi la résignation :
advienne que pourra.
"IKEA ferme, et alors? Ce sera
remplacé par une version russe.
D'ici un an, tout ira bien",
dit ce jeune homme.
Et dans le contexte tendu
actuel, il vaut mieux ne pas
leur demander ce qu'ils pensent
de la situation en Ukraine.
Car en plus de la censure
militaire imposée à tous les
médias, la Douma étudie une loi
qui menace désormais d'envoyer
toute ananananananananifeste
contre l'intervention militaire
en prison pour des années.
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-Canada, Saint-Pétersbou